i mean
she wins again and again and again and
again what does it feel like it's
overwhelming i'm still thinking it's
honestly soaking in what just happened
there's been like so much adrenaline
leading up to it and i'm i'm in awe and
i can't believe that it's back here in
calgary at home in alberta this is
insane and you had all of your family
there that has to be extra special i
would imagine it is very special i can't
wait to go find them all and hug them
plus you were performing plus you were
you were hosting tonight what was the
pressure like for hosting i mean
definitely felt pressure for hosting
i've never done anything quite like that
before so blanco was wonderful and it
was such a dream to get to do that
is there any drama backstage that we
need to know about like anything any
like wardrobe malfunctions were there
any tripping did anything happen no
tripping which is kind of shocking i do
love that too there was a slight
wardrobe malfunction with like some
sticky you know situations yeah that got
a little stressful for a minute but we i
had the best team back there with me and
we figured it out and there we were it
was good to go
what does it feel like the music that
you you have right now is the music that
you got all these awards for
how much attachment do you have to these
songs and and why do you think this year
was so big you know
this season of music came out of
creating it while we were all stuck at
home in the middle of the pandemic going
through so much as an entire world and
for me music was
my safe place it was like
keeping me sane to be able to still be
able to create and work on something
that brought me hope in a really dark
time so to have this music be
represented tonight is so
beautiful and overwhelming to me and
honestly these are the most personal
songs that i've ever shared and to have
people like stand up and say i feel the
same way and like the the exchange of
like the stories in that through this
whole season of these songs has been
just incredible to me so i do not take
that lightly i was so so honored to
receive album of the year tonight so
what is next for you i mean where do you
go from here well tomorrow fly back to
nashville and then we fly to australia
to play and we've got a tour in the uk
and germany and netherlands and then we
come back up to ontario for a run of
dates towards the end of the year so i'm
excited to close the rest of the year
out on the road and
be working on new music in the in the
time between and looking forward to
sharing more of that really soon amazing
congratulations thank you